i'm a big fan of looking at the same
problem in different ways or different
ways to conceptualize them and so for
example if i had a system of three
equations with three unknowns let me
just make one up three x
minus two y
minus z is equal to negative one that's
one equation and in three dimensions
this would represent a plane and then i
have another one two x
plus five y
plus z is equal to zero that would
represent another plane now if you had
two non-parallel planes they would
intersect each other and form a line but
then if we have a fourth plane so let me
write that as negative 4x
minus y is equal to eight it's possible
not always going to be the case but it's
possible that they will all intersect in
exactly one x y z coordinate and so in
other videos we talk about solving
systems of equations like this with
three equations and three unknowns now
what i want to do in this video is
connect this idea to the notion of
matrices and matrix multiplication which
we've already reviewed in other videos
so we can think of this exact same
problem in the following way if we take
all of the coefficients and we create a
three by three matrix with them
so let me do that so for example let me
get all of the x coefficients a three a
two and a negative four and i'll put it
in this first column here
three two and negative four let me get
all the y coefficients negative two
five and essentially a negative one
negative two five and a negative one and
then last but not least all the
coefficients on the z's a negative one a
plus one and then there's implicitly a
zero z here you can't see it so it would
be negative one
plus one and then a zero so these are
the coefficients on x and purple on y
and yellow and in like a salmon color
for the z's right over here if we said
that that is going to be multiplied by
a three dimensional vector
that is i guess we could say unknown x
y and z
that is going to be equal to a second
three dimensional vector which we do
know and that's negative one
zero
and eight and i know there's a lot of
things going on in your brain right now
you're like sal this looks somewhat
magical you just took the coefficients
put the xyz here put the right hand
sides of the equal sign in this case the
size that didn't have the variables on
it put it over here does this actually
make sense does this actually work and
to validate that let's actually multiply
out the left-hand side of this equation
right over here so in other videos we've
talked about multiplying a 3 by 3 matrix
times a in this case a 3 by 1 matrix and
this is going to actually give us a
three by one matrix so that's looking
good already and the reason why we know
that is
these two have to match
in order for the multiplication to even
be defined and then the dimensions of
the product are going to be three by one
but let's actually multiply things out
well we know one way to construct this
i'm just going to focus on the left hand
side here
is to say all right let's essentially
take this row
and this column
and then take the sum of the product of
the corresponding terms i guess you
could say so this is going to be 3 times
x
which is 3x minus 2 times y
minus 2i minus 1 times z minus 1 z
like that
and then the next one i'm going to take
all of this business and multiply it by
this column so it's going to be 2 times
x and this is just a review of
multiplying matrices
plus 5 times y
plus 5y
plus
1 times z
plus 1
z
and then last but not least if i take
this
and i do the same thing with that column
it's going to be negative 4 times x
negative 4x minus 1 times y
minus i could just write minus y and
then 0 times z which i could write if i
want to or not write but i could write
it let me just write it to make things
clear and so the product of what we have
on the left hand side is this right over
here and it might look like a three by
three but it's actually a three by one
here where this would eval if you knew
what x y and z is this is going to
evaluate to some number likewise this is
going to evaluate to some other number
and this is going to evaluate to another
number and we know from this i guess
you'd say matrix vector this matrix
equation that we've set up that this the
what the left-hand side this product
needs to be equal to
what we have on the right-hand side it
needs to be equal to
negative one zero and eight
which means and i think things might be
connecting for you now that this
needs to be equal to that
and that
this
needs to be equal to that and last but
not least negative four x minus y plus
zero z needs to be equal to eight which
is exactly what that original system of
equations was telling us
now i know well there's still probably
some things that are circulating in your
mind
one question is well that's all nice you
found a different way of representing
that but how do this introduce a new way
of solving this and the answer i'll give
you for now is yes it will lead to a new
way of solving this because if you think
about it we're taking the product of a
matrix and a vector here to get another
vector if there's some way to
essentially unwind this matrix
multiplication then you might be able to
do that apply it to this vector on the
right and then solve for this unknown
vector here and that's the way that
things like a computer a lot of computer
algorithms actually try to solve
problems like this by representing them
as matrices now another interesting
thing just with the representation
itself is it makes you think about the
problem a little bit differently you
could view this as three planes in three
dimensions and where what is the x y z
coordinates where they could intersect
or you could view this three by three
matrix here as a transformation matrix
that's applying to that's being applied
to some unknown three-dimensional vector
and under transformation that a known
three-dimensional vector is equal to
this known three-dimensional vector
negative one zero and eight
and so the question of solving this
would say all right can we somehow
perform a reverse transformation an
inverse transformation so to speak on
the right hand side to figure out what
that unknown vector really is and i'll
just leave you there and we'll continue
that line of thought in future videos